bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france d'abord cette
question sur l'évolution de l'épidémie à
moins de 15 jours du déconfinement vos
observations
je pense que c'est une décision vraiment
difficile et je pense que ça va être
assez juste parce que il y aura encore
d'après les estimations de pasteur
probablement pas loin de 1900 un peu en
dessous de 1900 personnes en réanimation
pour comique 19 et ça ça veut dire que
les services de réanimation sont encore
très encombré donc ça va être très très
limite ça risque de l'épidémie va
repartir et on sera parvenu à un stade
normal où il y aurait très peu de
patients hospitalisés pour kobe de 19 9
au 11 mai je le disais sept cent mille
personnes qui devrait être testé à
partir du 11 mai ce sera suffisant selon
vous pas vraiment d'autant plus qu'on ne
sait pas qui sont ces personnes qui vont
être testés c'est de la stratégie
d'utilisation des tests si on a cette
nuit c'est combien vous avez dix sept
cent mille 1 700 mille tests par semaine
c'est ça louis cession n'a si on a sept
cent mille tests par semaine à
disposition comment les utiliser au
mieux
est ce qu'il faut aller tester beaucoup
plus dans les régions où le départ où le
virus circule encore je pense que oui
et est-ce qu'il faut systématiquement
testés les cas dont on est quasiment
certain qu'ils ont la maladie sur des
critères cliniques ou radiologique
je pense que non et le problème de ce
virus c'est que la moitié des
contaminations sont le fait de personnes
qui ne se savent pas contaminés soit
parce qu'elles n'ont pas encore de
symptômes soit parce qu'elles n'en
auront jamais donc le problème c'est
cette circulation cachée du virus et
cette circulation caffier du virus on le
peut la trouver
quand est ce temps des gens qui n'ont
pas de symptômes pour les mettre à
l'écart et donc sans cette stratégie
d'utilisation des tests on va pas s'en
sortir
et on peut faire des choses plus
astucieuses avec le faible nombre de
tests qu'on a devant la population sait
qu'on peut faire des tests groupe et on
peut rassembler les prélèvements de
toutes les personnes de la même famille
et rechercher le virus dans le
prélèvement ainsi rassemblé ça coûte un
seul test et s'il est négatif on est
tranquille et on a utilisé - le test
nouvelles façons d'optimiser l'usagé des
tests d'abord il faut tout d'abord il
faudrait comprendre qu'ils sont les
personnes qui sont se contamine encore
aujourd'hui en période de confinement
parce que c'est là qu'il faut aller
chercher les expositions qui sont ces
gens qui se courent s'ils ont été
contaminés la semaine dernière qui sont
ces gens qui sont arrivés en réanimation
hier
ça c'est une question intéressante et
j'ai pas vu la réponse a alors ordonné
une autre question intéressante plus de
90% de la population n'est pas immunisée
cela veut dire quoi concrètement qu'est
ce que ça signifie pour l'après 11 mai
ça signifie que on a mis à travailler en
confinant la population parce qu'on
voulait réduire le nombre de malades si
on a réduit le nombre de malades on a
réduit le nombre de gens qui sont guéris
de la maladie donc la proportion des
gens est immunisée c'est à peu près 12 %
dans l'île de france et dans le
grotesque et c'est beaucoup beaucoup moi
par exemple en bretagne où un nouvel
aquitaine c'est pour ça que la situation
est très différente et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'il faut pas circuler d'une région
à l'autre pour propager le virus
il faut il faudra circuler en portant un
masque en tout cas le le port de masque
on sera obligatoire dans certaines
situations
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi ce port du masque peut réduire
les risques d'infection
la raison principale de porter un masque
c'est celle que je viens d'énoncer tout
à l'heure la plupart des gens qui
contamine en contamine d'autres ne
savent pas qu'ils sont contaminants
porter un masque est un geste altruiste
ou porter un masque pour si par hasard
vous êtes infectés ne pas cracher le
virus sur tout le monde donc il faut
porter des masques
il faut porter des masques à partir
d'aujourd'hui il faut porter des masques
partout sauf à l'intérieur de chez vous
et c'est très simple et les basques
grand public c'est mieux que panama
que du tout donc cette histoire de
masques et extraordinairement simple
porter des masques
quand vous êtes en dehors quand vous
êtes dans une magasin quand vous êtes
dans un moyen de transport quand vous
êtes dans un taxi quand vous êtes
n'importe où sur cible alors justement
sur le les conditions pour que ces
masques soit efficient qu'est-ce qu'il
faut justement privilégié quel type de
masque n'importe lequel chaque masque il
ya les matchs sont de plus en plus
efficaces partant du masque grand public
fait selon les normes afnor il ya plein
tutoriel sur internet etc qui sont pas
géniaux mais beaucoup mieux que rien
ensuite il ya les masques chirurgicaux
qui sont déjà mieux que les masques en
public et ensuite vous avez masques ffp2
qui sont encore mieux
c'est un problème de filtration mais
c'est exactement comme les tests quand
j'entends olivier verront dire on veut
pas testé tout le monde ici on teste
quelqu'un négatif il peut être positif
le lendemain vous avez déjà en testant
tout le monde enlevé tout ce qui était
positif aujourd'hui et leur dire vous
êtes positif êtres contaminants c'est
utile c'est pareil pour les masques vous
filtrez une partie des particules c'est
mieux que rien donc toujours critiquer
les trucs en disant c'est pas parfait
rien n'est parfait aucun test n'est
parfait arte pcr il ya des faux négatifs
tout des trucs ont des problèmes mais
chacun contribue et améliore un peu il
faut utiliser tous les moyens pendant
magasin merci beaucoup catherine hill je
rappelle que vous êtes épidémiologistes
merci à vous